[Music]
in a lot of ways technology has made our
lives easier but it's also um changed
things uh that have made me miss certain
things did i say that right i i'm
wistful i don't know what you're trying
to say yet well okay uh do i used to
love leaving voice messages and
recording uh my outgoing message and i
used to like leaving messages for other
people i find myself not doing it as
much because
now texting has become so people don't
call us that's what i'm trying to say
anyway uh but back when they did call
more i used to be really into my
outgoing message i also
have since retired my outgoing message
because it is grandma jody and it's um
one i obviously can't get rid of now so
um but
years ago when i was working with the
great mike judge the creator of beavis
and butthead i asked mike if he would
record my outgoing message and uh and he
obliged
he was very nice he in fact messed up
the first time i remember he he said uh
uh you've reached that yeah you've
reached justin's phone uh bibus and
butthead and
i had some friends call and they knew i
used to do like impressions and stuff on
my outgoing message and one friend
called i believe it was togo he left a
message he was like yeah not your best
impression but it was to uh mike's
actual message pretty funny yeah it was
the guy the actual guy but in a way
that's a braggy story because it means
that my he thought of my impressions as
being so good that right also the story
indicates how much
you care about grandma jody because
to record over mike judge
yes that says a lot about how much you
like the new message yes and mike judge
had recorded over
stephen root who did milton from another
mike judge movie yes you reached justin
long's phone maybe a future guest i hope
so but now we have uh
we'll get to in a second here it comes
it's the show life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening life is short i'm your
host justin long who has not gotten much
better at introductions
am i about to be honest brother
christian and coz you could argue that
you may be getting a little worse oh
you know because in fact so positively i
thought it was going to be like you
could argue that you have incrementally
improved
uh
i feel like you've gotten more
comfortable at being bad no at just
doing it without thinking too much about
it which is not necessarily good not
necessarily good but there's something
nice about
uh being really comfortable with
something and not and not holding
yourself to such a lofty precise
standard yeah i figure i mean for those
of you
just tuning in
uh i'm sorry but also i i feel like
listeners probably already know this we
don't do a lot of takes any takes i mean
once in a while we do one take we do one
take that's right we do one take well
that's not entirely true sometimes every
once in a while if you really [ __ ] the
bed for the first 30 seconds then you'll
be like all right let's start that over
yeah i see you you give me like a
deadpan look i've now gotten to know
what that look means it's like well
after 40 years i should hope so yeah but
it'll we'll have to start over but um
not on this one i guess no we're plowing
ahead so mike judge so mike why are we
talking about mike johnson well mike is
one of the great voices in animation and
um it's something that we grew up we
didn't grow up with beavis and bad we
did a little bit beavis and butthead
were really popular when we were in high
school sure uh we got really into it we
got cable a little bit later um and we
got scott but i used to watch it at
friend's house i remember watching you
you don't both have to watch the
previous butt head clandestinely at
friends houses because you didn't have
basic cable
clandestinely no
it was a little it felt a little naughty
it did it was punk rock yeah yeah i love
that show me too and it still holds up
it it made me laugh because i had
a more teenage sensibility and so they
were like you know a lot of that stuff
it worked on that level it did but i
appreciate it in a in a different way
now obviously some older yeah but it's
i think it's even funnier now you know
what else we liked
looney tunes
growing up when we were kids what an
understatement i mean looney tunes was
it was most of our it was our saturday
morning definitely um it just brought so
much joy and still does i'll watch it
every once in a while
and that still holds up still so good
god is it the comedy it's classic comedy
i mean it's classic for a reason
uh but really holds up is so [ __ ]
good that's one of our i would say
one of our top five
biggest influences
oh yeah
yeah it's right up there with um laurel
and hardy i would say yeah brothers mark
spread monty python i
yeah it's if you and it's interesting to
go back and watch those old shorts
because you see now
the you see the influence you see where
oh like oh i sometimes directly like oh
i got that exact
move of that line now i'm regretting
saying that because it sounds
like we're bragging well it sounds like
comedy we're in in any way putting
ourselves on the level of like oh i'm i
was inspired no no you just mean like
you're lots of humor yeah exactly yeah
um and it's and a lot of it is when you
watch it now again like you said about
beavers and butthead it's a lot smarter
than i i thought at the time than i
realized um because i've gotten smarter
why are we talking about looney tunes
well our guest today very special guest
um somebody that i was i read a story
about this is the first time i think
this has happened where i kind of
discovered somebody on social media
reached out to them and they were kind
enough to come on the show that's that's
how this happened our guest today is the
new voice uh like of these iconic
characters beavis and people's not
people i'm sorry see we might have to do
this again no that'll be funny really oh
yeah no take one but now people will see
that even this is one we don't exactly
okay you corrected yourself right away i
know we were talking about okay
okay so our guest today still same take
our christians making fun of me for my
hand motions that i'm doing our guest
today is uh the new voice of these
iconic characters bugs bunny daffy duck
the list goes on we're going to talk
about a lot of them uh our guest is eric
bowser eric is um
i think a genius when it comes to voices
so you discovered him on instagram yes
uh i he there was a big story about him
because
um space jam is coming out soon and
the new space jam
space jam 2 space jammier
lebron lebron is um the new michael
jordan yes right
yeah and we were of course
kids when the first one not kids we were
in i was in high school high school when
the first one came out um and i guess
that makes sense that lebron is the
michael church they're both of course
the best and um
the animation looks really cool but the
uh voices are now being done by eric
bowser and eric does so many of them uh
and his story is really interesting how
he was discovered um
and and where he comes up with these uh
how he how he's
cultivated these sounds are really
amazing he's um from canada he's from
toronto right
he's of filipino descent and he was
obsessed with looney tunes as a kid and
he cultivated a real passion
um for the cartoons and the voices and
and i know you guys talk about that we
talked to give it a little context yeah
exactly uh and it's something that i
related to
as as we said we watch them all the time
but it sounds like not nearly as uh
passionately as he was watching them he
was really
doing the voice and he he's mastered
them as you'll hear
and uh i just i was so intrigued by him
and i think you will be too so
let's get into it um
just prepare yourself for uh to have
your ears blown
can you say it like that yeah okay um
this is my
my meeting my my introduction to the uh
torchbearer of some of the most iconic
voices in history uh voices that i know
will bring you joy uh they have brought
us so much in our lifetime so here it is
my talk with the new legend eric bowser
life could be a dream
[Music]
hello
i would describe what you have as like
uh what
geniuses have that what you have is a
gift to do these voices is a real gift
how can you like how did you learn
beyond just listening over and over so
you say gift i say a lot of time on my
hand me and maybe yeah
the
crease in the shape of my body on my
couches we'll say otherwise
you know i mean we you and i probably
grew up watching the same stuff and it's
just basically like
for me it's it's you either landed on
the disney side of the fence or the
looney tune side of the fence i would
have all of this crap in my
[Music]
house pointing to you you got a big wb
uh looney tunes poster and it looks like
tweety bird where are you exactly
i'm in the corner of my bedroom
in los angeles
and uh yeah i i would own all of this
looney tunes apparel and uh toys and
artwork if i wasn't the voice of these
characters isn't that funny well that's
probably
has a lot to do with why you are you
were just you're you're in love with it
it was a passion when when did it start
eric was was it your earliest memories
as long as i could remember as far as
being able to sit up and watch tv on
saturday mornings and wow with a big
bowl of cereal and my big brother yeah
in canada in toronto they had like uh
lots of like channels not unlike bbc but
it's um
global globe they had this channel three
was global and they would rerun the bugs
bunny and tweety show the best and you
know it would be all the all the shorts
that were made in the golden era that
were never made for television these
were shorts of course that were packaged
with newsreels
something that they could play while
you're in line to get popcorn at the
concession stand yeah so that's
basically the introduction to cartoons
and melbourne i happen to cross your
story on on twitter and i started
looking at your stuff and i'm just i was
so blown away i meant though i reached
out to you i it's such a gift that you
have and i know you would you're
self-deprecating about it you're you're
being very humble about it but um i'm so
curious about it how you honed that how
how that came to be
so good really how it happened the
reason why we'll we'll talk about the
performances that mel blank left behind
80 years ago because bugs is 80 this
year wow uh wow years and we're still
talking about that's crazy the heart and
soul and life and sweat that he poured
into these characters not just bugs
you know not just bugs but uh of course
staffy duck as well let's uh let's not
leave out the real star here i'm
spitting all over my laptop
you are
it's amazing that you can go from one to
the other that's incredible to me oh
yeah uh rabbit thief and duck season
rabbit sleeping duck season
oh my god duck season fire you know like
it's
oh my god there's probably no way to
articulate
how you do what you do but do you need a
word do you need to get into bugs by
doing a certain word
it's kind of funny that you mentioned
that we could break down the voice i
could break down all the voices for you
i could break down i would love that uh
the mechanics of it i'm fascinated yeah
where it all rests you know of course uh
youtube of course is one of the first
places as an actor if there's a voice
match or a character that you are a
legacy character that you are embodying
you immediately just go into the
research you go to the original source
material uh but there are uh vocal
impressions or things that i like to
dissect by watching interviews of people
because that's when they're just kind of
you know in their natural
you know their their their natural
comfort zone
with their normal voice
as well as the characters that they're
portraying so
there's a very famous and
watched clip of mel blanc on david
letterman the letterman it's amazing
it's the go-to it's just he's so
respectful i mean he and he's just he
seems like such a sweet uh charming
man too like such a kind guy and i mean
we look up to letterman as being like
the king of like late night you know
like the classic one you know johnny
carson of course but then like for me
growing up in in the 90s i was a
letterman kid me too me too
you're on the east the east coast so i
mean
letterman was it uh i i'm from toronto
it's like i i almost forgot how to use a
shovel because i've been in la so long
but uh
you know there's something about living
through four seasons that makes you the
way you are it kind of it's great
yeah and you guys also had my i love
toronto you also had mike bullard oh
yeah open mic with mike bullard open my
night talk show that was the first talk
show i ever did for some reason he was
really into this tv show i was doing
that weirdly letterman produced uh
and bullard had i mean weren't there a
lot of similarities between those two he
had that he had kind of like even his
facial kicks sometimes reminding me kind
of like our attempt canada's attempt
it's always canada's attempt at whatever
is going on yeah
yeah
but yeah i would often go back and
research uh mel blanc on these
interviews and he would always be like
uh you see you know when we were coming
up with the voice when we came up with
the voice you know the chuck jones and
and uh bob clampett uh they would say if
a rabbit could talk you know he's a he's
a tough tough little stinker uh and we
wanted to say uh you know uh
what's the toughest voice uh but the
brooklyn of the bronx so we you know we
mix the two of them together and that's
how we came up with the bugs bunny duck
you know oh my god eric but it's it's
that level right up here if if if i'm
talking like bugs without the accent
and then kind of making a baby talk it
becomes tweety oh dwayne got a little
cat you
know they pitch that up a little bit
more
uh they pitch it up they pitch tweety up
they pitch tweety up bugs i think is
like mel's self pitching
and then you know we're talking about a
guy that like probably smoke cigarettes
at 10 in the morning all the way to like
11 at night yeah but eric you did
for people who aren't familiar with it
either stop this podcast now and check
out the youtube clip or or maybe you
know if it's too riveting uh just get
get through the podcast but listen to it
afterwards because it's watch it
afterwards rather it's a great it's such
a great uh interview and he's he goes
through all of them yeah yeah and you
just but you just did his his speaking
voice was so
rich and you you slipped into it it was
beautiful so for letterman to be like uh
a a an institute a staple in american
broadcasting he's sitting next to this
guy
that was he reveres him in in like radio
you know like yeah when it was only
radio and
that's why you know when mel blanc
speaks he speaks so clear
because back in the 40s if you were on
radio or even sorry the 30s
if you weren't clear then you weren't
heard so everything he did was so
clipped and so pronounced and
right oh my god what what would he think
of the way
i mean i'm gonna sound so old but the
way kids are
the way kids are talking now it's like
because there's no respect for you know
that kind of clarity the enunciation
that he had i i mean
because he he lived all the way till 89
so
you know from like the the heyday of the
golden era of animation to 1989 he
probably you know i wonder
what
and and also i mean you talk about that
just the animation itself i'm now
remembering it being so it was beautiful
compared to the stuff they do today the
way they churn it out today it's tough
it is a real tough comparison because
this is two two of my theories obviously
that are that are so obvious it's like
number one
they weren't up against uh tight
deadlines there were no streaming
channels there was no like we need it
yesterday it was like here's a story
you have nine months to make this seven
minute short nine months right nine
months now
you know the things you can make in nine
months with overseas
digital age they were still doing pencil
paper i mean i have uh
gosh do you have any stills i i have
okay i have so much i have so much
animation art in my house oh i bet i'm
gonna i have one right here i'm gonna
grab for you you might like uh please
you you grab yours i'm gonna grab mine
okay eric's gone to get his
uh i'm gonna show him one that i have
i'm gonna describe to the audience uh
because he's gonna get to just see it
it's this it's a still from beavis and
butthead
whoa
cool huh
yeah you got the gold mine right there
yeah i got that's my brother christian's
do you do yeah you're into you doing
that hey hey bayless oh justin has our
cell whoa whoa
i hope my judge is listening well
oh my god oh damn it you you don't have
any tom anderson cells in there do you
because he's my favorite
uh well i love oh god i love it mike
judge i met him once i had a chance to
record him um i was working at an
animation studio that required his voice
in it and i went to his office in santa
monica he was just there
editing uh i think it was like a either
his show on rock and roll or he had a
rock and roll documentary and you see
this guy that has you know
in the lexicon of animation develop
these voices
that you know you've made it when you
know i i i'm the seventh guy in a voice
bugs bunny i won't be the last uh but
the real goal as a voiceover artist as
you know as an actor it's like to create
that character yeah yeah that everyone's
going to imitate right and mike judge
has clearly with with effort
effortlessly without even trying
you know those two voices i know well
now i want to hear i'm going to tell a
judge story maybe in the intro but i
i've worked with mike a bunch and i i
now want to hear you were talking about
mel blanket reminded me of hearing mike
for the first time and hearing because i
knew beavis and butthead so well before
obviously i'd i met mike and i'm sure
you had the same experience
what did mike sound like to you like
obviously you can hear both beavis and
butthead in his voice but um
it's definitely anderson and uh
i wanna hear your mic he was like uh you
guys uh you guys mind taking the stairs
instead of the elevator like he just
didn't want to take the elevator he's
like let's just go up and i was just
like yeah sure and he's like and um you
know when
when we record do you mind if i just
turn the like the microphone away you
know i just you know
i was like eric i go i know it's weird i
i don't like when people watch me doing
these weird voices either oh he wanted
to actually turn away from you he was
you know a little like i just kind of
like i gotta do my thing over here yeah
that makes sense i was like do what you
need to do i'm just gonna watch the
levels i had a small recording device oh
my god what was that
what was that before i think it was like
a commercial for like uh
it was like a ufc commercial like an
animated ufc commercial with hank hill
uh
and uh
you know he was just talking about ufc
and how much he loves it as much as he
loves propane and propane accessories
you know my god that's that is so good
but that's what i mean it's like this
this it's like watching the three
stooges it's like there's this rhythm
and language that he speaks yeah that
that's you know what every voiceover
dreams of is like this weird thing that
you can do creating i was going to ask
you about that eric because yeah
obviously what is what you're now your
bread and butter and what's brought you
to this prominence is uh our characters
like you said that exist but do you have
so that is that would be your goal too
is creating a world
and creating characters yeah like
eventually i mean it's it's something
that i think uh
it just has to be the right ingredients
yeah because aside from being able to do
voices
you know i'm not a scriptwriter so the
story's got to be there from a
storyteller like a director but you're
an animator you can draw you oh yeah i
was just drawing this uh before before
you hopped on i did this uh oh my god
he's showing me a bugs bunny like
then fred an
bernie on the other side barney
perfectly done i would say if you had
shown me that if you had erased whatever
the uh
you know the stationary is on that and
just said
well these are originals actually i
purchased these i have to go i haven't
got them framed yet i believe you
i would have believed you did you do
fred and barney
uh uh you could do a an approximation of
uh bonnie rubble uh hey friend uh we
gotta go bowling with betty and wilma
uh and then uh
i mean alan reid with the original voice
of fred flintstone i mean that's one of
the hardest
wilma wilma where's where's pebbles and
dino you know he had a very
uh a very deep gravelly voice uh he was
he was the inmate in the movie breakfast
at tiffany's that uh hepburn would visit
he was the big guy in jail
oh my god you watch that scene back and
just close your eyes it's a fred
flintstone just talking about being in
jail oh my god yeah you know all that
i'm looking at him right now that's
right oh my god alan reid i'm thinking
now eric you are in like a very rarefied
position where you can
in the future when people when you go up
to people they know your face or
whatever
uh
you're going to be able to talk to any
family because
every family is going to be so excited
to have
bugs or daffy or whoever it is that they
know or you the characters that you'll
create one day oh my god will you do the
voice uh you must get it all the time
i'm gonna hit you up oh absolutely when
my nephew gets into bugs bunny don't
think you're not getting any time you
know i'm here for every birthday of his
until he's 18 and when he's sick of it
you know
happy birthday again from your pal bugs
funny like you just insert name here i
will do it for you man well what's great
is that it makes um and i know my people
my own age uh older older like you said
it's been going on 80 years i'm sure it
has the same effect on them where
immediately you feel this childlike
sense of excitement when i hear you do
that i'm looking at you
and um and when you do that voice it
just it makes me so
happy
and i feel like that's you know it's
again one of the hardest voices to
replicate uh
80 years later we know bugs like we know
like our grandpa or an uncle yeah or a
relative or in some cases better
yeah
yeah i mean in my case
we use we use these cartoons as an
escape and again it's like
they make us happy and and
we want to root for this guy but it's
like so well known that as soon as you
start to go
out
people scrutinize it yeah absolutely and
rightfully so they're they're i'm a
diehard fan like when i first watched um
it was bugs bunny's 51st and a half
birthday spectacular and it was one of
the first shorts to be made post mel
blanc
uh the first guy to voice bugs after mel
blanc passed away was jeff bergman uh
and he uh continued to do the voice on
tiny toon adventures with steven
spielberg
as well as he was the begin like in the
movie gremlins 2 at the very beginning
when the warner brothers shield comes to
the screen
bugs and daffy have an argument about
who gets to ride the shield and that was
jeff jeff was the guy oh 30 years of you
on this shield is enough you know like
it's my turn
oh it might be all right
oh yeah by the way that was my warm-up
word for bugs is all right but when he
says all right in a cartoon it's just
all right okay then okay all right
yeah all right yeah all right you got it
oh my god all right all right oh my god
the warm-up word for for daffy for
whatever reason is the word chickens
every time i say chickens it's staffing
oh and also daffy just happens to be my
richard dreyfuss impression with a lisp
oh that's great oh my god
what we're dealing with here is a
perfect eating machine
all this machine wants to do is eat and
make little baby sharks and that is all
it really is a miracle you know oh my
god you're going to ignore this prop
yeah i used to do that line it seems to
me you're going to ignore this problem
until it swims up and bites you yeah
oh that is really i'm telling you
you got daffy
oh my god wait will you do that again
will you do that dreyfuss yes yeah wait
wait wait so
what's the sharks sharks are
we do try those what we're dealing with
here is a perfect eating machine you
know
oh my marianne moffatt mary ellen
moffatt she broke my heart
she broke my
but when mel does it when mel did daffy
oddly enough it's it's almost uh you can
equate it to trey parker doing eric
cartman on south park uh well back in
the day uh i think if you watch
basketball you know you see that scene
where trey parker is going hey you guys
seriously like he was doing cartman like
with the scratchy voice oh you know i've
never seen basketball i'm embarrassed to
say i love south park if you see the
documentary seven days to air it
profiles how south park episodes made it
surprise it surprised me to see him do
cartman but just as um
sounded like just a heavier guy like
when he was doing the voice in the in
behind the mic like i want a new laptop
mama like he was doing this voice and
then they would speed that up and
magically it would become cartman like
oh come on you know like it was just so
strange with
daffy mel blanc is actually doing
sylvester's voice and then they speed it
up
fo so sylvester lives down here like i'm
gonna catch that little bird and eat him
for lunch uh and then when he dumps
you're despicable and you pitch that up
it becomes staffy you're despicable oh
weird vocal thing that that
i was surprised to find out that how did
you discover that eric that that's an
amazing discovery uh the sylvester daffy
where how did you find that there are
some excerpts from uh some of the old
box sets of looney tunes from the 90s
that they released and uh they're easily
found on youtube but you hear mel blank
in the booth like uncut going
okay here are some taffy duck lines to
be sped up
at 20 rpms or 10 rpms and you hear the
formula so he's like this guy is a wives
cracker you're a despicable rabbit
and then that would become daffy but
when i perform daffy it's already
i'm already
you do it naturally yeah
jesus eric but your natural voice i'm
noticing you you're so you seem so
comfortable in that lower register does
it hurt does it do you strain yourself
when you're doing either daffy or bugs
because it sounds like you're going so
much higher i mean
with almost any uh if you're talking for
an extended amount of time that's a
strain and of course i think over the
years having been voicing multiple
characters um yeah uh it just it just
happens um oddly enough there are some
weird voices that you wouldn't think
caused like a string like i voice uh uh
baby fozzie on muppet babies for disney
oh my god ah hey comet wakka wakka
why did the chicken cross the playground
to get to the other slide
well because it's bad that wack
froggy cloggy voice yeah
yeah if you're doing it in the morning
and you haven't like you know if you're
not sleeping with a humidifier by your
bed and your voice is all cracky
boy it is a hard voice to make sound
smooth
that's interesting eric we i talked to
howie mandel on this show about um
yeah
he talked about that but he described i
forget exactly i forget the word he used
it was a way of where he cut off his um
he kind of stopped up the back of his i
don't know how to how you just like
breathing like or like layering yeah
it's just what it's what anyone can do
you just you just stop it
but he doesn't sound like marvin the
martian
oh we were just talking about him
christian and i were talking about oh
marvin george marvin and george that we
love that dynamic of a really big uh
it's just again classic comedy this this
big oafish physically imposing
uh but submissive character
yeah about the abominable snowman right
i will call him george i will love him
and kiss him yeah
yeah and then and then marvin isn't that
lovely very uh he sounded like this
first actually if you watched the very
first marvin short he was rather nibbish
and and a bit more subtle but then he
evolved into this earthquake
i enjoy your podcast justin but it
blocks my view of venus
that's great
but it provides a perfect view of uranus
and i i'm just i'm weak yes yes oh yes
it was more kind of like hmm yeah yeah
it's so weird that that guy's a he wants
to blow up our planet uh because he
sounds so like
nonchalant yeah yeah oh i i i'm i'm not
hurt just terribly i'm not angry just
terribly terribly hurt
yeah you know that's great i wonder it's
interesting that that fozzie should
should be at all uh strain i i just
wonder
what muscles you you're using it is very
strange and you know uh uh if you're a
voiceover artist and you know or a
singer uh a vocal performer having a
good uh ear nose and throat specialist
ent will save you from um you from
losing your voice you go to dr nazarian
i i go to dr warren line in uh oh okay
in burbank he's like right by disney and
okay most of the the vo guys uh my my
buddy justin roiland he's the creator of
a show called rick and morty uh yeah or
he is uh you should you should have him
on here he's an interesting guy i would
love that what a great show yeah um
that's one of those shows that became
like a cult hit
like it's first overnight you know yeah
i had i had known him for for years
before and i always knew that as soon as
he had his chance to tell a story uh for
a large audience that it would snowball
into something insane but well now eric
is that the kind of thing you're talking
about like the goal uh in terms of you
know the gifts that you have and then
and then attaching those to some
some material that just speaks to you
that would be the you know just an aside
and and you can include mike judge in
that in that uh
uh realm uh i was uh lucky enough to
bump into uh seth macfarlane at a
comic-con party there was a party at san
diego comic-con which i'm sure you've
been to many yeah yeah you know and i
just i just had to i pulled them aside i
was like hey man you know
uh i do the some of the looney tunes
voices but like
you are
like the definition of like like mel
blank you could you could say i do mel
blank voices but you look at someone
like seth macfarlane
that he's created created like not just
like i mean like an entire city like
quahog you know like he he populated
just like trey parker and matt stone
it's like they are south park they they
have created
hundreds and like of performances and
different characters and
that's something else
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
what was the biggest
leap that you took i mean how did you go
from being a kid who was just obsessed
with this stuff to you got an agent you
got how does that work well it's like
doing the internship here in l.a i
worked at an animation studio and uh
you know that lasted for a little little
under a year and then
i went back to toronto to finish school
and graduate but years later it was the
friendships that i made they eventually
left that studio and started working at
places like warner brothers and disney
and nickelodeon and these animator
friends of mine would be like hey i
remembered that you
expressed your passion and love for
voices
just from that internship that year-long
internship and and that was for what
exactly eric that was i was just a
production assistant and an animation
studio here in la and
again the best outcome of that was the
the friendships and and years later i
mean two three years later so it was
like 2005
that i kind of made that leap
to move here i couldn't do that without
my family here i got i got family
members out here
and you know rent is expensive it was
expensive back in 2003 and it's even
more expensive in 2020
and sure
and this was before you were i mean now
of course you're
you've found the success you're you're
doing all these voices and but but when
you don't have that i mean when you're
going out there with you've got a few
contacts and you've got friends in
animation but like how do you because
actually people ask me this all the time
and i never know what to say to them how
do i go from i do some voices i like
doing voices how do i
who do i send a tape to or who do i who
do i do how do i do it yeah well it
starts with that demo reel right
i had no idea me my first demo reel was
like a cd that was like 20 minutes long
and it was a real like impressions but
it's like of people that are like alive
and well like like beerus and butthead
and like didn't like homer simpson homer
was on there too marge i'm so hungry oh
homer don't eat that donut it's full of
cholesterol
but marge
i'm starving yeah so it's like oh my god
like impressions of people that are
alive and well like there was no need
for that it's like it's great to show
your range but again if you're listening
and you are throwing your first demo
together make sure it's no longer than a
minute and it has
original characters and acting uh the
acting is so what you could do wacky
voices that's great that'll get you in
the door maybe but what keeps you in the
room is solid acting
and it it's the so what i'm voicing a
cartoon rabbit but you have to care
about this character uh yeah and which
sounds like you obviously do
but so okay so you got the 20-minute
tape and um
so then how does that translate into
even a meeting yeah with the right
people again basically
the first real big american gig and
again one of the reasons why i left
canada at the time was
there wasn't a lot of original animation
and original content being produced in
toronto and
canadian actors don't get residuals like
like the americans do we get uh you know
these canadian voice actors to come in
here they're going to steal allied jobs
you know it's disgusting these guys they
they might be polite i assume but you
know we got to build a wall of these
what they call putin it's the food in
canada it's french fries gravy and
cheese putin i think i could have poop
in my mouth all day it's delicious uh
but you know thank god that's great
what was the the thing that i mean bugs
bunny
obviously is probably the most iconic
animated character how did was that just
an audi were they did you know they were
looking for somebody to knew and
you had an agent at that point
so i was already
after 2007 working on a on a show called
el tigre which was directed by um
that was like pretty much the first
through a friend kind of like oh i heard
that you like voice acting and you know
we're trying to get more diverse even in
2007
this couple from tijuana uh uh sandre uh
uh sandra akiwa and jorge gutierrez they
directed a movie called book of life it
came out just before coco came out with
pixar and it was kind of like of the
same you know very rich in uh mexican
culture and lore and um
dia de los muertos uh was the main
subject and uh
uh they hired me on a show called lt
gray and then i thought you know i was i
was moonlighting so i was still working
in animation and then i would drive to
nickelodeon
do the voice acting then come back to
the studio and oh my goodness
and i was like oh wow i'm on a show it's
going to last for 30 years like the
simpsons and then literally a year later
they cancelled it
yeah and then like yeah back to the
drawing board for me uh yeah and then
literally
2007 to 2011
they in 2011 they they had this reboot
or a reimagining of looney tubes called
the looney tune show and i imagine this
was around
the even like
second or third height of family guy
being an animated sitcom
and they're like well let's just make
bugs and daffy roommates and all the
characters live in this cul-de-sac it'll
be like an animated sitcom style it was
written very dry
uh and that was jeff bergman's return to
the characters and that's when i started
voicing marvin
uh
oh you started as marvin that was your
first marvin was my first in 2011
and then they that show came and went
and then sorry eric sorry to interrupt
was that just that this is probably
boring for people but i'm curious was
that just an audition yeah
oh yeah they had audition bugs daffy
porky they auditioned everybody
and uh
i read for everybody and they did yeah
and they're like we love your marvin we
think you're great as marvin so i was
like see that's surprising to me because
not not that they loved your marvin but
that they
would not want you to do others because
they all seem
god i'm closing my eyes sometimes when
you're doing them and i'm sure people at
home can't see you do them so
i can't hear
it sounds so perfect to me i and i know
you've been honing it well yeah you can
imagine i i you know i i hardly really
ever keep any of the auditions that i do
i just kind of you know
especially when you don't you don't book
whatever you just toss it you just get
it out right yeah uh
because you don't want to be too
attached you don't want to feel like
butt hurt about not booking something
but part of the show is marvin i'm like
if you're going to be anyone you might
as well be the most popular golf head
cover you know
ever made that's true exactly he was
only in like four shorts in like the
original 30-year run and he's one of the
most popular characters oh my god that's
funny i i mean he's like they're all for
the most part iconic characters uh
absolutely
yeah can you i love one of my favorites
is um uh the the oh my god um
uh oh i'm blank the rooster oh why can't
i think of his name i said i say fog fog
fog
yeah that me too i uh you know
she she's like the freeway between here
and san diego no curves uh you know it's
like
yeah like a centipede at a toll counting
contest uh
yeah who do you who do you think of i
mean do you think of do you visualize
those characters you had mentioned
earlier that um you have you
you have somebody else in mind sometimes
there's another you know richard
dreyfuss let's say uh do you do you do
that trick with any of the other
characters like look again a foghorn i
believe the origin of his voice i think
there was like some cop or some sheriff
that mel blank knew that was hard of
hearing
oh it's not from uh it's not from that
paul newman movie yeah uh what we have
here is failure to communicate right i
feel like that is also something that
may have had an influence but i feel
like his he said his was very specific
to like this cop or like this
down south cop that was hard of hearing
so he would always be like i said
you're not paying attention do you hear
me boy you know like he was he was kind
of i said you're going too fast
i see the lights are on but nobody's
home you know it's it's that it's that
those weird phrases yeah and
insults you know like
people want to see familiar i mean like
that's why these characters there's a
reason they've stuck around of course
they're great and they're so well
written but like um you talk about
wanting to create your own thing and
rick and morty and how these shows every
once in a while will break um uh it's
it's there's i think they're so few and
far between because you know people are
just it's just an easier sell to be like
let's do
bugs and daffy again let's dust off uh
and also they don't have to pay for it
they own it it's all right it's in the
library right so
do they get weird with you like well
they get weird with you for doing voices
outside of their property they trust me
enough that i uh here are the keys to
the cadillac you can take it for a drive
around the block don't scratch it you
know don't that's cool
they're totally fine and and they know
how how much they care about these
characters yeah they're pretty
trustworthy and i think that to me is
like wow like
yeah that in itself for me is like a
huge honor but um so looney tunes show
came and went literally
a year goes by and then they start
production on another reboot of looney
tunes this time it's called
at the very beginning they're like we're
gonna strip away
all of the characters we're just gonna
have it uh bugs living in his hole in
the forest and a bunch of new
adversaries so like new characters huh
but you're you're making a bug's money
cartoon and then somewhere down the line
someone says you know would be great
if if elmer fudd just kind of came in
and did a thing and then he leaves and
then you're like okay we'll do that one
but you know it would be even better if
if you said so then it just started
becoming yeah looney tunes again
uh
is what i thought they should have
called it but but they called it new
looney tunes so there was the looney
tune show
then new looney tunes uh and i was
better than nooney tunes and then and
then when that came and went it's 2018
and they audition they open it back up
the email comes in
if you're only seeing this audition come
in for the first time in 10 years you're
gonna read for it and yeah and again
with looney tunes cartoons they went
back to the drawing board again
literally they're like it's back to
basics it's
the 1940s style we want to hear the
sensibility and sound
i mean i ate carrots in my audition like
when i when i submitted it did you oh
wow there's like a little bowl of baby
carrots and it's like
you know there's nothing quite like
you know like just crunching those that
crunch yeah
yeah i wonder if mel blanc did that i
wonder if he he he did but apparently he
was allergic to carrots
get out of here so if he was chewing
carrots there would be a waste back it
waste basket or a bucket close by that
he would spit out and an epipen yeah
or or a whole pack of cigarettes that's
usually
right right give me some that was
unfiltered
right those were the antihistamines back
in the 1940s
smoke this pack of cigarettes and burn
some garbage in your backyard for 40
minutes and you will be cured that was
the claritin of the
1940s so
and there there you have it i mean like
that's kind of how i got it so i got in
his bugs i got in his daffy i got it in
his tweety they they kept me on his
marvin
oh my god and it's it's been insane so
with that so that was 2018 eric and then
around that 2020 already
that was 2020. so 2018 is when we
started production in 2020 march of 2020
we premiered looney tunes cartoons and
we also premiered covet 19. that's also
they both came out yeah in the same
month both uh one receives better than
the other
sure we got to cancel the latter so yeah
yes i can't wait for that to be canceled
um yeah how would you uh what would your
covet voice be if if i said uh
voice that you know that
[ __ ] red
microscopic thing
hey come on if i just sit here on your
couch i won't i won't take up any space
it's just like i'd rather you leave
covet i
i'd rather you leave you've been here
for a while it's time to go i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna take racism with me
oh great that's okay i
hadn't even considered that in a perfect
world that's what i this is you know the
heavy part of my conversation you know
and i know it's probably a subject that
everyone always talks about now is like
represent representation of of people of
color even in voiceover
whereas when i entered voiceover the
idea was it didn't matter what you
looked like right right but then there's
the abuse of like you know
okay i'm voicing a character that is not
of my culture
when it comes down to it we're looking
at it from the point of view of like now
black lives matter and again it's one of
those hashtags and catchphrases that i'm
like it's 20 20. shouldn't we all we
should know this people like should we
know that i know
don't be racist like i know like it's
not it's not rocket science and
you know but we we it's here and we have
to talk about it yeah and it's not going
to leave overnight i get it but when it
comes into voiceover like people like
mike henry stepping down
from uh cleveland brown on family guy
all right a character that he's voiced
for the better part of 20 years
no one made complaints about it and when
you hear it to me it doesn't sound like
he's doing like
you know a racist interpretation of a
culture that isn't his it sounds like
he's doing a very specific impression of
someone that he knows um but he stepped
down with without anyone asking him to
he did it on his own merit and uh but
they found a voice replacement who is of
african-american descent and he's a very
good impressionist
and and he is doing his best impression
this is where the con this is
hopefully a conversation starter for
anyone listening it's like this is where
we would have like a white actor and
another african-american actor in to
weigh in on that because it's not
exactly
you know when you're looking at it on
paper it's not exactly
like making it better or is it making it
worse that's the question
that's the interesting thing that's
where this conversation becomes very
interesting and like you said necessary
because i feel like we all have to
get on the same page i mean like that's
what this is about i'm getting on the
same page and like kind of figuring out
because this is so much of this
unchartered territory i mean just some
stuff that we have not talked about like
yeah like at this level under this like
magnification under microscope right so
for instance i got an audition uh under
nda i can't say what it was but the main
character is the filipino
guy
but the iconic characters like of this
reboot that everyone knows
are not human they're from outer space
right uh and i i get the audition and
i'm like
i'm reading it i'm reading it going oh
so wait i'm only reading for this guy
and now i can't read for those guys who
are aliens from another planet uh that's
interesting they're hoping to get the
real alien like real
species from there um
wow that's so i talked to my agent and
i'm like can i not read for those ones
is that oh is it okay and they're like
oh of course of course but that's what
i'm saying where it's like
like we're trying to be too good to a
fault where now we're excluding
we're only inclusive to i can only
return you know i'm not a real rabbit i
hope i don't get cancelled for voicing
bugs buddy
yeah
wow wait so because so eric your your
background is
filipino and so god i feel like you've
dropped enough hints about what this
thing that you can't talk about is that
i sh i should know but i don't know what
you're talking about the um that you
signed the nda for uh
so is that something that you got that
you no no i i i you know i read for it
okay maybe i wasn't filipino enough uh
okay okay but then you move on but it's
kind of just like again i i love
fighting for diversity you know being a
a kid growing up in toronto
the one of the most diverse cities uh in
in the universe uh
and
but and again making sure everyone is
treated fairly and especially under the
microscope right now you know black
lives matter all for that but to the
point now i i want to get i hope that
we've we can solve and open up a
dialogue that
you know
fixes it and i know again it's not going
to happen overnight but i i want to get
back to that point where we can make fun
of ourselves
if there is anything that you know
like being
too politically correct has eliminated
is the ability to laugh at ourselves and
and say hey yeah i'm different like when
i tell you this fact you're going to
laugh like you know you're going to look
at the lineage of the voice of bugs
bunny and you're going to see six white
dudes and then me at the end like the
kid from up you know like yeah he's like
hey yeah yeah i love balloons and
hanging out with old white men and i
also voice bugs money you know i want to
get to that level where i know i know i
mean it's it's it's interesting to hear
you say that because um i agree but it's
also i haven't had
a lot of people might say and rightly so
well yeah of course you want to get that
because you haven't had those struggles
like as a white guy you haven't had to
um
deal with a lot of that adversity and so
it's interesting to hear you say that
somebody who i'm sure even though you
came from a very
as you said inclusive progressive city
uh i'm sure you faced a degree of
exclusion
and that's the funny thing i'm trying to
think and i feel like almost
maybe not all the cultures i'm not
saying i'm like that's a miracle right
like to say i've lived in a world where
i haven't you know no one's asked me
what you know what what math uh you know
what a matter i'm a reverse asian i'm
good at parking and bad at math uh you
know
i'm reversed but it's like it's like one
of those things where i was lucky
i couldn't laugh at that i would not i
mean that you gave me license to laugh
at that um oh by the way i don't know
what you're talking about um i don't
know by the way my name is ken zhang and
uh
but what was it it's also toronto
happens to be a very uniquely
like you said diverse very different i
grew up in a high school where i was
friends with people from poland and and
the east and west uh you know indies and
and like all over the world it's like
so what was your association with your
ethnicity was it something that you even
considered often or was it a thing that
like your parents maybe cooked a certain
way and you're great they spoke you know
funny well you're talking about uh
parents that like love the food network
you know they live they like making
filipino food but they also love making
like just any kind of food my mom used
to make curry and roti like
uh real west indian and east indian food
and wow uh pierogies like polish oh
polish yeah yeah
my mom made great pierogies and gowonky
oh wow that's funny because i had they
did they grow up in toronto your parents
were they they came from they immigrated
from the philippines in the 60s and uh
my brother and i were born in toronto
and
wow you know uh that you know if you're
gonna relate it back to uh voices
those accents were the first things that
i heard you know like oh i bet i bet
when i go to toronto my mom's like eric
we have to visit your grandmother at the
cemetery i'm like the cemetery and she's
like yeah they symmetry
where they make cement yeah
[Laughter]
the cementery
that that i was gonna ask you you did
impressions of family members then other
family members oh yeah i mean like we
would have impressions of everyone like
all our uncles and aunts everyone had a
very particular way of speaking even if
we shared the same accent it was such a
different you know again it's
personalities
everyone can do a new york accent but
like like bugs money but it's it's the
personality behind that accent that
makes the character makes the person
that you're a person right
when i think of those characters i think
of and this might be
you know you talk about like
racism that is just embedded in us it is
just in our marrow because it's part of
uh systemic racism that i think whoa
i just assume bugs bunny is voiced by a
white man right it's just i just assume
it and an old man yeah it's not just the
mel blanc thing it's like because it's
such an old character and for some
reason i just i associate that voice
with whiteness
it's funny you mentioned that because
again i was at a uh
the
intellectual property like trade show
like when when warner brothers in disney
and all the companies we're talking
serial companies anything that has a
brand that can be like the licensing
show in vegas
this was like that must have been fun
literally like i've never been invited
to one of these things there's no
purpose for a voice actor it's just a
showcase to show off what's coming out
yeah movies tv
anything that could be printed on a
shirt or a lunchbox
but eric they would ask you to do i mean
isn't there some concern for somebody
like you because they would
i i'm trying to remember with alvin like
there was usually like they would
separate
i i'm trying to remember how those
contracts work but uh it may be
different for warner brothers but
wouldn't you then voice those uh
in the commercial for
you know whatever cheerios for the most
part but again you know jeff bergman uh
and billy west they're still alive and
can do the voice as well for bruh okay
and i think that's like warner brothers
protecting themselves so they're not
just beholden to one person but uh yeah
and again i'm working with these guys
that practically raised me as a child so
it's like hey i'm cool if he wants to
take this round go nuts yeah uh yeah but
when i was at that trade show in vegas i
met the representatives from warner
brothers mexico
and they're like you're the voice of
bugs money
oh that's funny that's kind of funny and
i was like yeah and then they're like
the guy waves his friends over two other
guys from mexico come over and they're
like he's the voice of bugs bunny and i
was like oh uh why is it so surprising
and exactly word for word they're like
when i think of bugs bunny i think of an
old balding fat white guy
and you're much thinner and you have
more hair
um
that's honey well i'm glad to know that
i'm as racist as some mexican trade show
guys nobody else you know it is just one
of those things where you're just like
yeah you're right though because i mean
yeah i mean what have you been finding
that i mean that's a very obvious thing
way to confront it and way to hear it
but do you ever find
it does it come in other forms do you
get i don't know comments on social
media like uh are are people even i
would i would think even people trying
to be complimentary and still being
racist oh like oh wait maybe there was a
like one weather woman in canada that
was like the way she imported it they
ran that story and they're like
that voice coming out of that face i
mean he's talented like she immediately
yeah but you can't really just say that
face anymore without it having more than
one meaning
right right
yeah what like a dimpled face
oh that's funny um but well that's and
also great i mean it's amazing that you
are because
it there there is still a ways to go
absolutely this is just my first year in
this in this role and hopefully not the
last but if you're gonna go back to
representation
if you are listening or watching or or
have seen me in interviews doing this
voice and you and i share the same face
or not or you you are a different or
even if you're just shy to use your
voice no matter what race you are or how
short you are or how tall you are
if if there's anything that i can say
it's just like use your voice don't be
afraid to speak and and
if you have a passion for acting or
voice over give it a shot don't give up
on yourself because again
i'm sure
with your experiences if you take
yourself out if you don't believe in
yourself then you're just kind of like
you'll always wonder
that's the thing and that's that's the
great thing about you were lucky i mean
it sounds like you came from an
exceptionally inclusive and tolerant and
your parents seemed like they were
forward thinking so
you didn't have the struggles but i'm
sure there are a lot of kids who do look
like you goateed goateed children who um
you know
kids who are asian or african-american
or whatever it is that uh
see you and and because you've done this
they now think that it gives them
license to to even dream about it
absolutely and and that's if that's the
one if there's that spark
that i may have inspired in someone i
i'm so for it and and encouraging so
cool there are moments where i was
starting and i had no one to talk to and
uh
now we're living in this age where you
can just reach out and contact somebody
and it's like yeah i'm all for it i'm
like yeah you wanna you wanna talk about
voiceover we can talk about voice over
till the sun comes up so well it's great
and also i love that the character
itself and these these characters that
you are voicing are coming back because
i
have missed them in pop culture and and
i i'm so glad that a generation like my
nephews um are going to be now exposed
to to these characters and that
you are the torchbearer of these icons
and like i said i will i will do pointy
greetings whatever they want anytime
justin any time i didn't get to show you
this you showed me the the beavers and
butt head cell so this is oh yeah okay
so eric's showing me a cell this is from
the original michael jordan bugs bunny
nike oh okay so i got my shirt i got my
oh i got my
i got my uh
mars blackman shirt that's amazing
that's cool so this was the the second
commercial
they were two super bowl commercials one
was 1992
and it was bugs bunny in a gymnasium
getting bullied by a bunch of jocks uh
were they oh 1992. so that was air and
hair jordan
uh yeah so successful i bought the shoes
i bought the shirt two years later they
came out with another ad with bugs bunny
michael jordan and marvin the martian
and it's like oh goody all the air
jordans on earth you know he stole them
and then two years later than space jam
so
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
had space champ been announced when you
got um when you started doing bugs by
the time you would order i started doing
bugs and then uh you know i can i can
neither confirm uh confirm or deny my
presence on that film the warner
brothers attorneys are outside
they're right they have their sniper
rifles aimed at my forehead um
but bang just
i'm picturing a flag now coming out of
those sniper rifles we're we're in cart
full cartoon territory oh yeah but
there's an answer one of them is holding
an acme something or other
take one step to the right please on
that red x
but what i can say is this i grew up in
this this weird
mishmash of like why don't we put the
looney tunes with this guy and they'll
sell this and we can sell that
and i loved space jam 1996 um i was
walking down uh kennedy station in
toronto our subway station by my house
and
walked down the stairs
every uh on the subway platform every
poster was the
it was like this uh i have i have two of
them i bought them off ebay
and i signed i had i had d bradley baker
the voice of daffy duck in the original
spaceship and billy west the voice of
bugs bunny signed my posters for me on
one of my birthdays it was like no way
nerd uh but i i remember these posters
and i was like god so cool
and uh
another fun fact if if you have the
space jam soundtrack there is a track on
there called buggin and it's bugs bunny
rapping it's like who does bugs bunny
money i'll give me some time to get more
carrots every time i rhyme can a mouse
write this does he have long for his
ears like this uh and uh that song was
performed by billy west you know from
futurama fame he's also the red eminem
um
oh no yeah
and it was written by uh sean carter aka
jay-z
he was like oh really he's just like
we'll just use my real name on this one
but what's my nerdier name it's it's the
most played track on my space jam cd
no
kidding that's so cool listen to that
song you'll be like laughing your ass
off
oh my god did you eric did you do the
voices for the kids and i'm picturing
you like with a group of like high
school kids oh middle school kids around
you i was the kid that had to sit in the
front of the class because of all the
trouble that i would make but
when the teachers in the back of the
class they can't see my face
our secretary her name was jan corey and
she sounded like marge simpson's sisters
she sounded like patty and selma like
i i imagine that she would smoke
cigarettes i'm not sure yeah so you
would see the back of my head like this
and i would disguise my voice
to make it sound like it was coming out
of the pa system and i would call myself
out of class
so no
[ __ ] that's great witnesses
like oh my god and so the teacher would
just not question it she'd be okay all
right yeah you heard her go to the
office can we see our thousand please he
needs to come to the main office so like
i would leave and people would be like
the you know like wait a minute eric how
did you make it sound like it was coming
out of the pa system it was like
it's just i just was able to throw my
voice i don't know how it worked it just
sounded like it because
oh my god
this king that was my teacher miss king
was at the back i was at the front and
it just whatever sounded it sounded like
it was coming out of a speaker
wait will you do it again um uh miss
miss k it's miss corey can eric please
come to the main office
we need him to come down to the main
office now please so like oh i made it
sound like i was in trouble so she
believed it
and it was urgency yeah the stakes were
high so i had i left and for about 20
minutes i was just you know eating junk
food out of the vending machine that
would come back
right after high school did you go right
into um college college i took radio
television and film uh broadcasting in
the uh
in the the campus uh in toronto where
they actually shot a show called
degrassi junior high it was like a very
god joey jeremiah was at my graduation
jeremiah no kidding and it sucks because
i know he has a real name
i know i know i should know that i know
that's not cool uh oh my god no way it
was called the bell center uh a branch
off of centennial college and on the
drive in it was also the same backdrop
for the intro to the old kids in the
hall show
i would see all like the same places i'm
like wow this is
you know i brought up sctv and
people like mike myers and jim carrey
like mike myers is from scarborough so
it's just like this weird like
something's in the water in toronto that
makes it honey you just said yeah funny
and talented you just said scarborough
like mike myers i just heard him in your
voice
um he's like who was your who's your
favorite mike myers to do his characters
you know everyone does and i said you
know lauren michael's
dr evil
you know we'd make meat helmets he'd
make outrageous claims like i invented
the question mark
uh and and in my voiceover career i've
worked with people like mindy sterling
and seth green and i oh great help oh
you did um seth with seth you you did uh
robot chicken uh i haven't done a robot
chicken i have done voices at his studio
and we were both on ninja turtles
he was no kidding he was leonardo and i
was uh
a tiger club his original character uh
oh mike how did tiger claw go uh
tiger club was a yakuza um assassin and
he was very if if bebop and rocksteady
were larry and curly tiger claw was moe
he was like he actually killed people
okay wow that is such a yeah he had the
more sinister mo was more sinister than
that
what a great uh what a great comparison
yeah yeah what a great analogy in terms
of doing impressions really quick eric
are you visualizing the person are you
is there are you doing mannerisms of
theirs are you doing physicalizing them
in any way you know like if i do jeff
bridges man you know like i've seen jeff
bridges you know talk in person and uh
and i've heard i've heard him uh talk
about how he pitched the sequel to king
kong he wrote a song about it you know
it was very bizarre like how would you
would you pick up a movie from jeff
bridges if he sang
if he sang a song like you know that
would be so weird you know
oh my god i'm saying you know we're
going to talk about uh big celebrities
like robert downey jr you know rdjs the
kids like to call me uh you know i've
seen a an alien steal a necklace from a
wizard piece in our time uh it's just a
very bizarre thing and you know i i also
did an approximation of uh paul giamatti
you know when you do poultry about you
have to pretend like you're trying to
bite your shoulders you know it's like
this oh my god that's great you know
your childhood
car commercials now like he's got that
very
howard stern
hey hey hey robin look look at this guy
this guy when we call him pig vomit okay
because he looks like a pig and he makes
me want to vomit uh howard stannis you
wrote you soiled the sanctity of my home
oh my god your face is taking on yeah
it's taking on different shapes that's
incredible as a voice actor you know
when you're behind the mic you just do
anything you can to get that voice out
okay really quick uh what is your
favorite emoji eric oh man my most used
emoji is the is the worried smile with
the sweat coming down
oh yeah like the one drop that like yeah
that's like the few phew
uh in the emoji movie i voiced uh
the sad emoji
oh my god
oh great i just want a million dollars
it was just like i was always sad
that's great you know you know that's
that classic film that everyone loves so
much if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play oh man
uh basketball for sure of a big
[Music]
have you met lebron were you able to
i've worked with lebron i've spent time
in the booth with lebron oh cool okay
all right that's awesome um if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be oh man uh
oh that's a tough one
man uh sour cream and onion chips sour
cream and onion yeah why not lays a good
like what's a good toronto chip oh man
ketchup chips
oh yeah that's so funny kristen shaw
speaking of creative voice actors
kristen uh
from bob's burgers was just i just saw
on instagram she said um
she was talking about those ketchup
chips that's a canadian thing it's it's
weird because every time i'll bring it
up you know most americans are like ugh
just eating ketchup but i'm like but
it's not a potato chip so it's like what
do you dip your fries in and they're
like ketchup and i'm like what's a
potato like a ketchup chip they're like
no that's just eating ketchup
that's funny uh yeah what is your
favorite movie sequel of all time
speaking of space jam 2. ghostbusters 2
is it really yeah
do you do
the igor who was that peter mcnichols
action figure and it comes with baby
oscar from the movie like the oh my god
like the weirdest accessory
hey dana
yeah like that that movie is great
that's great
dana
that's funny
that's that you don't like it better
than the original but it but no the
original cannot be top but the fact that
they changed the logo in the movie to
like the logo of the like you know like
they're just the ghostbusters but not
they're not ghostbusters too
but they changed it in the movie and
that that was the most funny and unusual
things i remember that's right that's
right they changed it on their uniforms
in the sequel you're right and how would
they know that there was a
it's a movie it's it's too meta that's
way too much
yeah yeah i guess you could say that
what okay your go-to you must be do you
have a uh
as beautiful a singing voice as i think
you might have
really you don't have to sing
what did they do on the rainy night in
rio a rigging think what do they do when
there ain't no starry sky
oh where did they go when they can't go
for a walk do they stay home and talk or
do they sit inside
my god have you ever done that in a
carrier in it like a public karaoke bar
no but they probably kicked me out
immediately
like nails on the chalkboard
when is when have you because it's like
to me it's like a super power what you
can do have you whenever you ever used
it for like
when have i ever used it what what gets
me through us customs the fastest is
these voices when i'm getting my
passport stamped and they see that work
visa they go so what do you
what are you doing here what's your
business here in the u.s and it's like i
work in animation like what do you do
i'm like uh
voices and then they go from this like
i'm gonna give you like a full cavity
search to
like 12 year old kids going okay yeah do
that one and then you know you're doing
these voices while people are waiting in
line and then they're like who the hell
you know they hear me doing woody
woodpecker like i do that for universal
like
you know like doing that laugh
hey i'm 21 peckham for universal and uh
and i'm smuggling a brick of heroin in
my luggage and you you don't care
because you're you've just stamped my
passport and i'm good to go it's like oh
my god yeah and it's loud so people are
listening yeah people can you can't help
it you know like you have to do it that
loud and then
you know most u.s customs agents like my
kids love you can
you know can can you like leave a
message or like you know like you asked
customers oh you must have left so many
messages for so many kids for drawings i
would just draw on the spot and uh oh
wow you know that that that's that's
where i use it the most is at the border
if you had had to get a tattoo i don't
know if you have any uh if but if you
had to get one or if you wanted another
one what would you get and what oh man
i'm just wondering what i want to be
stuck with for the rest of my life right
i know that's the thing would it be
would it be a character would it be one
of these iconic probably it would
probably have to be bugs bunny it would
probably be either bugs bunny doing that
classic like lean against the wall
eating a carrot like you know yeah
um and and do you remember remember
having a first celebrity crush uh
again we probably have the same
touch oh my gosh it would it would
probably be uh uh chrissy snow from
three's company suzanne summers oh sure
yeah oh i love three's company that was
my show man uh
don't
impression you know jack jack we need to
you know
oh that's great
oh my god hey you know the first one i
ever did was max wright oh yeah from
albuquerque my god that's so good
remember i had a macbook
alf
elf get back into the garage uh the
ocmonics are coming
uh he oh really
where's kate where's brian huh uh oh
that's great you know i'll kill myself
there
alf they're gone right now alf could you
just
uh could you he was it was exact god but
we gotta take this on the road we're
gonna do it man uh dooley julie willis
is
yes
well that sounds a little
uh in the first 10 minutes of his
like the pinching between the eyes yes
yes yeah oh
oh kate and i alph why did you take a
dump in the washing machine you know
yeah i thought it was a toilet
how this is
all over my clothes
okay sorry i know you got to go well who
what's your favorite fruit oh uh
man it's a toss-up between uh
cantaloupe or uh or apples like classic
apple you know
somebody else said cantaloupe without
missing a beat our lad the last one was
cantaloupe um
that's interesting i can't i don't say
that's i can't stand cantaloupe but a
really ripe cantaloupe i guess it'd have
to be super ripe nothing worse than that
yeah
cantaloupe that's not ready
um who do you want who would you want to
play you in a in the eric bowers of bio
oh man that is a that is a crazy
question uh either either uh margaret
cho or uh
i have a female point of view it doesn't
have to be male it could be a female
sure you know brings us back to our
previous conversation or dante bosco
classic uh he's another another actor
from the philippines uh he played rufio
in
as well what's your uh who's your
favorite you're talking about the
simpsons who is your favorite simpsons
character oh man i mean it's might be
too hard no i mean like boy okay
obviously everyone would have if i were
a kid it would have been bart uh as as a
is bart hard for you to do because it's
so hot bart is almost next near
impossible that's an empty cart right
but you know home restimption is always
fun to do marge
but i mean uh chief wiggum for me
uh baker boy toys uh get off the stage
sweetheart you know hank azaria is a
genius uh suspect is heading towards the
place where they sell chili uh he is
dire he's traveling directly under the
sun
now suspect is helpless i repeat hatless
oh that's great you know there's some
there's some dna that wiggum shares now
with with bugs there's something
old-fashioned
and i mean like look at all of the
things that uh hank azaria's done like
with voiceover he's just he is like
modern-day mel blank god well maybe
they'll ask you to do i mean if god
forbid anything happens to any of them
or or uh you know you had mentioned that
there are that's a good example there
are some uh there were asian characters
on that show yeah i wonder if they would
then approach you to do
one of those another character named
akira he was the guy that he ran the
dojo uh but he's not hardly ever
featured in in the show but i could tell
he's definitely doing like a george uh
takai uh impression
and i feel like uh or takei i should say
i feel like they should probably just
get george him to do that voice
right yeah oh my god are you you might
let me end on this because i do i do
have to skip battle but i will end on my
george
story i was doing an episode of
scooby-doo
and there were two actors that i saw on
the call sheet aside from my own
uh that were george takei and uh james
hong
uh
as you know james hong was the father
cassandra in wayne's world two
as well as every asian bad guy from the
beginning of film up until now like i
mean the guy did the test of time
sharpest attack one of the funniest
actors i've ever had the chance to see
act in a booth
oh yeah big trouble in little china you
will never become a kung fu master paul
in kung fu panda he was
jack black's dad
um
he couldn't make the session
and they asked me to stay
to read lines with george because i was
done for the day
and i was like uh read with george
takei
yes i will stay the extra hour
for free to sit in a room with george
you know
sulu from star trek and we were he comes
in he's like oh hello how are you and i
was like
good now nice to meet you and i'm like
sitting down they had me sitting for
some reason i usually stand and this
older gentleman's standing for like
hours and it's time to go to break
and he goes oh mr bowser before we go
and break it may i say you do a better
jimmy hong than jimmy hong
and i was like jimmy hong by the way not
james hung but jimmy hong
uh and um
and then uh i'm at the you know coffee
machine and the voice director colette
sunderman comes out and she's like
george isn't isn't eric great isn't he
great you know and he goes uh may i also
say that mr bowser you are i and oral
candy
so he
he basically
it's like a like like a blessing from
the pope himself uh
you know and i was like spell oral i was
like well don't spell it because i want
it to be a mystery uh oh that is so
great it's so he he has such an
incredible voice and is such cl exudes
so much class that even him like kind of
like hitting on you and being like
mildly inappropriate is like weirdly
classy i'm like
i'll take it
i'll take that okay
and i will take that that what a great
story what a great way to end too
because that and it just showed the
range to go from who else can do that to
go from tweety bird and bugs bunny to
george to k uh eric you really are i
mean i i am in awe of you i'm likewise
so glad likewise you were you you've
entertained my myself my family my i
told my dad i was gonna get uh to talk
to you and he was thrilled you know you
you you have a huge fan base in toronto
canada and uh and in me uh but with that
being said yeah
that's all folks that's how you attend
tonight
i don't want to say anything else but i
just did i ruined it oh great thank you
so much
that happened happen happy i can't do it
it's hard to even attempt after that you
know what when you attempt an iconic
voice like that and
you can't fully do it perfectly it's
very noticeable yeah i noticed that a
little bit during your talk you got you
you really nailed some of those voices
some i can you know more like oh when
you miss one yeah
it's it's
awesome
hanging out yeah it sure is uh us and
everyone knows everyone knows everyone
knows them which is why what he does is
so
it's like extra impressive it's one
thing and he talked about how um with it
what a dream it would be to create a
character the way mike judge did and uh
mel blank of course did but
i think it is
in a way more impressive to nail
those already established characters
yeah i just think it's a different
different skill but for sure i think
what he does is
insanely remarkable it's remarkable and
uh krishna is here
that he can hear
the nuances between and compare them and
say this is like this guy
plus this guy
plus uh you know he's it's he's like
built but these voices but i noticed
that he does it's interesting that he
does that because um
that's what you have to do as an actor
he you have to ground them you have to
give them you have to contextualize them
uh in a more personal way and that
that's what he does he's the way he
talks about where the voices come from
they all come from like a very um
organic place he said so this guy is
somebody that you know an impression
that he did or something something that
he was comfortable with and he sort of
dials it up or he does something to it
he affects it in a way that keeps it
equally organic and so he he's also has
to it's not it's one thing to like do
the voices but to act uh that's the
that's the extra impressive thing to
perform within those voices yeah as much
as i love mike judge and and his sense
of humor mike judge
you can hear him you can hear all his
characters in his regular voice yeah
they're all all all and he does that
impression of mike yeah really really
good too and it's all like kind of like
that and even with mel blanc we just
watched an old um interview that you
guys should watch uh david letterman
even mel blank kind of sounds like
an amalgamation of a lot of those
characters but but i noticed about eric
he doesn't really his normal speaking
voice doesn't really
that's not true tip off any of those
characters that's true exactly if you
met him it's really impressive yeah like
he's able to like truly transform his
voice whereas right i mean
mel blanc is a genius obviously as is
mike judge but
you can hear them in their characters
and you can't with him yeah there's
something mel blank kind of talked like
there was there was a bit of that and he
eric mentioned this that he was a pack a
day smoker i just we just read that
since he was nine years old mel blank
smoked a pack a day and so he had a
naturally
kind of he and he it's interesting to
then hear him do the where those
different voices come from but you're
right he you can hear it but they're
also
creating these characters
and you know that's what did i i wish i
had asked him what seth macfarlane does
i mean there's other people who do that
they create these characters but it's i
just think it's a different skill set
and i hope one day
eric does i'm sure he will create
his own iconic character well because
he's also not only is he so passionate
about it but he's funny and he's really
funny really funny and he uh is is
just so versatile so
to your point i think
you know somebody who can who who
naturally sounds so different than those
iconic characters right there's
no telling how many he can come up with
i think there's um
there's someone who can do what he can
do it's it's so remarkable that i feel
like the only way you can do that is
an incredible combination of
a great ear like we said like an amazing
natural gift to be able to hear things
and
tons of hard work and passion and
and effort yeah like you need to do what
he can do that that level of
genius you have to be really into you
have to be both
really talented and really committed i
know there's a type of dedication that
is you need it yeah also i noticed about
him he's obviously such a nice person
um like uh he has like seems like a
mensch yeah he has like a
real
spirit yeah he is like a real positive
yeah positive um kind spirit
and i feel like the only way you can do
some of those voices or all of those
voices
those iconic voices is if you
um
love it like you need to love what
you're doing in order to pull that off
well didn't you notice that about mel
blanc in that interview he's got like a
twin mel blank this is 1982 he passed
away in 89 so he was
quite a bit older he was in the 70s but
he still had this like
child-like twinkle in his eyes when he
was doing those and those characters and
uh and
i i think you're right i think and to
bring them to life in such a
animated right it's not just doing the
voice yeah it's injecting it with joy
he has a real joy yeah yeah can you
imagine
i think about like
you know uh life how
how best to live a life like the ideal
way
to to live and i think about um
bringing happiness to people would be
you know when people pass away like
laurel and hardy had there's a great
inscription on one of their i think it's
stan laurel's tombstone that it says
something like he brought
happiness to the word to the world to
many and and it's you know it's so
simple but there's something really like
well it's hard to do yeah
hard to reach that many people it's hard
exactly but
that's what eric gets to do and it seems
like he really relishes it
that kind of gift to me um and it is a
real gift it's it's a power too it
couldn't be in the hands of like a nicer
more appreciative yeah i agree it was
daffy duck right that he said
um it's richard dreyfuss
yes that was amazing oh my god because
that's one of the oh not to make it
about me but uh i love doing richard
drive his impression you know and that
was the best way what a good teacher
he'd be such a good like he should do
that master class thing
teach uh voices that's a good idea yeah
because uh dreyfuss it seems to me
you're going to ignore this problem it
sounds just like him
with a lisp
unless it if it swims up and bites you
on the ass
is that pretty good yeah i was just
focused on your face doing it oh is it
horrifying horrifying
well well he's yes he was a little
that's good it's like goals yeah i i
heard you i mean you were jealous of him
i was right but you were like in awe
so you admire him yeah every time he
slipped into a voice you'd be like
oh god
i would i it's amazing i
i i
mean it i know i know it's so cool when
i was a kid you know the i the thought
of like one of those characters calling
us up and by the way speaking of that
i'm gonna you should take them up on
that offer god are you kidding i they're
i'm just gonna say there's into our
nephew is into bugs bunny now oh that's
right brilliant oh my god i can't wait
and i have friends with kids who uh oh
i'm really gonna milk that relationship
eric if you're listening to this get
ready you're gonna get a lot of requests
i i always wish i could do it but he
would love to do it he i believed him
he's like i'll do as many as you want i
don't believe him i completely believed
it i wish i did it because i did alvin
in the everyone i know no but i wish it
was a character that like i do i could
do i know and i don't know you need to
like a machine and to speed it up and
stuff well you could carry around the
machine with you just like a boombox
style i guess so it might be a little uh
might freak kids out a little bit
because i'd have to with alvin i have to
do everything slowly it really is hard
to i can hear it i can hear you in that
character but it's difficult yeah kind
of yeah it's not the same and you had a
pretty good alpha at the end there too
oh oh we did yeah that's good oh he
he's he slips right into it it's amazing
that he doesn't have to think about it i
know it shows how much work he's put
into it i know it's second nature got it
loaded it's like with with most voices
even the ones i fancy myself able to do
i gotta think or i have to have a work
that's why i asked him if he needs like
a centering word you know like with he
did yeah yeah yeah but that he can i
could never do that to go from
uh to go from daffy to bugs to have a
dialogue like that he's a real artist
and i i fully believe that he's going to
create
some iconic characters of his own does
he do marvin oh marvin the martian does
she how's that
now i'm doing it without the pressure of
having him it's pretty good
yeah but you're right when somebody like
that is doing them it's like anything
less is like ah well it's like playing
catch with tom brady
right it's right no it's like playing a
game with tom brady you wouldn't play
catch with tom brady i'm sure you'd be
fine you'd be embarrassed playing catch
with tom brady a throwing don't tell me
you wouldn't i wouldn't be embarrassed
catching with with him but throwing back
to him well that's part of catch i guess
you have to throw back to him
it's not fetch it's catch
that's true i could play fetch with tom
brady even that would be scary it would
be embarrassing in a different way yeah
cause catching imagine one of those boss
i'm picturing you playing fetch or him
playing fetch with you what would be you
would play a fetch with him
oh no hey
shag these a couple of fly balls not fly
balls uh hail mary's all right well
let's read a letter okay which voice
should i read it in
uh please do yours
or elf oh
but they could recast him oh alf no alf
kate and i were willie
that's pretty good yeah really where's
you know what it is because i naturally
sound a little bit like house
you do
i also i've been told i sound a little
bit like the dog in um
in
what's it called the stuff and crawling
show oh
what is that guy called uh brian
yeah i do yeah brian the dog i've been
told that a bunch yeah and who's the guy
in bob's burgers of course we've been
through this uh
who's that guy that you sound like john
john john benjamin yeah
but it's not about me justin no i know i
want to watch more family guy i haven't
uh seen him i liked it a lot in college
it's been a while since i've seen it
um okay this is from brittany
robbins
subject save your money folks
justin and christian greetings from a
moderately friendly acupuncturist from
alaska cool
i like that moderately friendly that's
kind of like brian kind of like me yeah
thank you
i love the show the comfort and laughs
it brings each week are priceless let me
save thanks brittany let me save you
both a potential 5000 bucks and a google
search
okay if your buddy anthony is
disregarding position slash oh
it's about mackie anthony matthews oh
yeah the uh having boys having boys okay
so anthony's a little context for um
anthony mackey was on and he
uh he insisted that he had done
something that created only boys he has
four boys and he's got a method that he
charges people that he knows five
thousand dollars yeah to learn from him
so that's why britney says let me save
you both potential 5000 bucks and a
google search and then of course you
wouldn't tell me what it was
if your buddy anthony this is back to
brittany if your buddy anthony is
disregarding position slash dietary
hacks to choose the sex of his babies
which he was it hadn't he said it had
nothing to do with position or diet
brittany says he's probably practicing
the shuttles method
although it's been mostly debunked in
the latest research some folks swear by
it i wonder if anthony's listening he's
pissed
uh the method boils down to male versus
female sperm and their supposed
difference in motility
in the environment produced by the
mother what's motility i don't know
maybe mobility did she mean mobility
maybe
or we're stupid we don't know the word
oh [ __ ] i gotta google it motility
motility uh
i've never heard of it
oh it it's a word
motility stupid yep
the quality or state of being motile oh
all that okay yeah
okay capability of movement sperm
motility
two the ability of the muscles is the
dutch of the letter no no i'm just
reading uh motility
so it's about sperm oh oh the motility
is the ability of an organism to move
independently using metabolic energy
okay huh wow what a word motility um
so it boils down to male versus female
sperm and there's supposed difference in
motility in the environment produced by
the mother i.e more acidic versus
alkaline depending on how close she is
to the date of ovulation technically i
think he just got lucky literally and
figuratively that's funny
t uh t l d r t l d r uh we learned what
that meant recently yeah isn't it too
long didn't read
like i'm gonna sum it up for you oh too
too long slash didn't read don't read
don't read don't too long don't read
like this is the cliff's notes okay okay
and then okay and she says have sex
earlier in the fertile window of a
woman's cycle for a boy
closer to ovulation for a girl huh okay
interesting
that's the shuttle's method that's not
worth five thousand dollars no by the
way i'd be so pissed if i was one of
anthony's good friends who spent five
thousand dollars um i'd want my money
back and i want to ask him that if any
of them
but of course if he says it and it works
it's like all right well you did say you
promised this is the one thing that i
was supposed to get was a boy out of
this
i'd like a little girl i've been i've
been seeing okay anyway
while i've got your attention here are a
couple of classic would you rathers i
found on the interwebs that i'm curious
to hear your answers to okay great
number one would you rather be able to
talk to animals i've thought about that
a lot or no
or know this
or know the history of any object you
touched
talk to animals oh wait sorry can you
repeat this would you rather be
picturing you
like dreaming in bed with like a little
dream bubble above your head where
you're just like
having tea parties
tea parties yeah um
mostly birds around here so many deer
too be fun to talk to you would you
rather be able to talk to animals or
know the history of any object you
touched
huh
um
that second part that second one would
be cool
but uh
most objects i touched a touch are
pretty benign it would be like this came
from a factory in china at some point
yeah this [ __ ] stone has been here
for me
[Music]
this waterloo this can of water loose
seltzer that would be interesting though
i don't know if i have enough curiosity
about objects that i touch i would
i would like that skill for sure yeah i
would rather have the skill of talking
to animals but remember this because
we've talked animals got mad at me no if
animals were just like i'm hungry i'm
horny i'm horny and hungry if they're
just they're like i have to pay i have
to they they just are basically don't
let them do that you don't have to talk
back i know but it might get i'm saying
it would get kind of boring and fun and
potentially weird to just hear a
cacophony of like i'm horny i'm hungry
i'm horny hungry hurry i think in this
hypothetical you could turn off the
dialogue yeah it's be able to talk to
them have a conversation right so
especially now in spring time i'm
picturing all these like horny animals
would you rather talk to deer or birds
hmm
uh probably birds because i meet more of
them
[Music]
and they're they're more plentiful like
you know i'm
i i lie for that reason because there's
more of them yeah yeah i could use that
yeah i could use that power more like we
were down in florida there's so many
cool pelicans and herons and
i i'd like to talk to them at deer i
mean
also once i've talked to the deer here
in the yard
it'd probably be like kind of boring
they'd be like oh yeah i would ask them
why they um what would you ask a deer
i would ask them if it how much it
bothers them that their uh ecosystem is
being uh messed with by humans
it would be
course what do you think they're gonna
say oh i'm okay with it what are you
gonna talk to birds about how would they
like to fly yeah flying would be cool
and talk to you do you really like worms
that much or is it just more convenient
to eat uh
what's your what's your greatest um
kill like what's the best um oh that see
that would be more interesting for a
deer i think deer just eat shrubs and
stuff they don't eat other animals
i would say to a pelican like i thought
they were omnivore omnivores what do you
what animals do you think of deer eats
i'm gonna animal shame you raccoons
get out of here
uh okay have i been saying that a lot
get out of here i've got this old-timey
i like get out of here like you're
getting much money yeah you're getting
older no i think it's from listening to
some bugs bunnies got old like yeah
what's up jack there's something kind of
old-fashioned about his there is
catchphrases he's like rat packy
yeah
ah what you don't say he's like dean
martin adjacent
he is thank you well that was the story
we didn't do anything right dean martin
was just like ring-a-ding-ding yeah he
had like a drink and he was like kind of
pilled up i think sammy davis was the
best one i think we've talked about we
have we have he's the most talented okay
okay there's another would you rather uh
number two would you rather have skin
that changes color based on your
emotions
huh or tattoos appear all over your body
depicting what you did yesterday
thanks for that this is great
um and then she says thanks for the
weekly dose of entertainment cheers
brittany r thank you brittany these are
great um rather skin that changes color
based on your emotions or tattoos appear
all over your body depicting what you
did yesterday i i would have the skin
change i would too
because the tattoos you are potentially
embarrassing too for sure and also you
always have tattoos all over your body
and i don't want that right well i also
don't want my skin to change but also if
i was angry about something and i turned
presumably red you wear clothes
uh i would yes but i would also
make an extra effort to get more zen
and control my emotions better it would
motivate me to control my emotions
better to be more like whereas what you
did yesterday
you can't control that everyone does
stuff every day right also it would be
there would you control your emotions
though also think about this it's true
there'd be at least
one or two maybe more
tattoos of you uh sitting on the toilet
i wouldn't mind that because my tattoos
all over my body it would be hard to
differentiate why were we talking about
oh um
uh the drummer um not uh from from uh
blink um
travis parker yes uh travis barker
apparently got a tattoo of um
he's dating one of the kardashians i
can't believe i know this he's daddy and
kardashian and he got a tattoo over but
but then it showed a picture of him and
he's got tattoos all over his body he's
like um
what's that show blind spot or that show
where that person has the tattoos well
you thought that it wasn't a big we had
a disagreement about that yeah because
my point was that it's not like a big
move it's not like that uh
because he's got so many of them anyway
it's not like getting if you had no
tattoos and you get um
chloe or
jaden smith
like sal but see my argument was that it
is a big move
because he has so many tattoos that he
has very little
skin space left to get a tattoo yeah so
he has to be extra discerning about what
tattoo he gets i think based on the
photo i saw he probably got it over one
oh that's different or like inside but
let's say he didn't let's say he used
let's say he has five percent remaining
space for tattoos on his skin yeah then
you're right that's a big move it's more
precious
yeah um also i know people speaking of
changing colors you know there's those
kids in school who are like very very
fair-skinned
who would like when they got upset when
they started
they would get beat red they get flushed
yeah they'd be like uh their face would
always kind of felt bad for those people
me too it'd be like a red roar shock
test
yeah
yeah they would get you know who's like
that is chris and i were really into 90
day fiance and um
this might be too deep a cut to say but
too late uh no backing out now mike on
90 day fiance he gets really flushed and
yeah his his skin changes color he wears
emotions his emotion is always
frustration
because he's stuck in a relationship he
doesn't want to be with someone who's
like kind of great really great really
great in fact i i will say all the
people from other countries the
international with the exception of
maybe ziad they're uh they're great and
more impressive than their american
counterparts i don't mind yet uh really
yes yes yes all right uh we should get
yet on the show anyway uh thanks
brittany r and that's a great letter
thanks for clearing that up about the um
shadows method yeah interesting take
that anthony um if anyone was curious
that's actually that's a great
that's i'm so glad she did that because
i have been curious about that ever
since
uh so thank you brittany and thank you
to the um
immensely talented the
uh
new icon eric bowser very kind very
impressive man
star
kind yeah star of this summer's
gigantic yeah smash hit i'm sure you
don't need us to tell you space jam um
is there like a is it space jam 2 or is
it just like a remake of space jam i
don't know i think it's just space jam
do you know what i can't believe i'm
saying this at the end of this episode
this is going to be a little scandalous
you've never seen space jam no really
have you yeah
bill murray's in it oh yeah a lot of
people are in it i think i was just too
i i
i think i just missed you you were a
little old you just graduated i think
from high school yeah and i went through
a period where i thought cartoons were
for kids you know and then later in my
20s when i discovered um
well when i got more into uh certain
you know herbicides
when i
got more into like
it's so nerdy uh yeah i rediscovered how
how great it is
but but space jam i missed so you should
watch it i'm going to and i'm going to
see the new one i'm excited for it um
who else is in space jam 2.
um a lot of nba players
yeah uh do you know anyone else in it
well and most importantly eric bowser
yeah so why lebron james yeah oh yeah of
course so um
and bugs by everyone you know you're
gonna see it we don't have to talk about
it but uh eric is um is going to be
great in it because he's great and if
you guys would like to write us a letter
we like getting your letters even the um
even the critical ones yeah
and not that this was critical at all it
was actually quite the opposite it was
complimentary and interesting and
informative mad informative yeah mad
informative our email addresses life is
short at wondery.com and we will talk to
you next week so uh
that's
awesome were you trying to like hurry it
up
i wanted to cut you off anyway that's
all folks uh that's all thanks eric and
everyone for listening
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced and co-hosted by you
christian long as well as produced by
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
mieshlands
uh the audio engineer on this one is our
friend newly haircutted sergio enriquez
and also having recently gotten a
haircut i think in the last year at
least is executive producer marshall
louie for wondering
[Music]
kate and i
you know
now kate and i we
rather you not come on the trip
oh
you